I'll be honest with you the hardest part
about this quarantine for me is that I
miss my staff I wanted to find a way
that I could I don't know be with them
well the person who came to mind is my
associate producer Jordan shlonsky yeah
I I thought it'd be great if I could
interact with Jordan in a meaningful way
and so I was cruising around on the
internet looking for a product that
would help me do this and I found one I
promise you this is not an ad it's
called a fur bow it's a dog
camera it allows you to stay in touch
with your pets and even give them a
treat I ordered a fur Beaufort Jordan
shlonsky and I had it sent to his home
when I told him to install it earlier
today and I got the fur bow app I just
connected right now this is the point of
view from the fur bow so I think he can
hear me Jordan Jordan Jordan its Godin
yes I'm checking in on you because
you're you're like in some ways a pet to
me if I want to see how you were doing
pal okay why don't you have a seat
Jordan so I'm not looking at your sack
okay I find the way you're dressed
totally unprofessional I did tell you I
was going to contact you sometime today
didn't I
we're natural fibers it allows my skin
to breathe have you been behaving
yourself I don't know what your criteria
is but I live by a moral code you say
that you're a good guy even a good boy
right
I wouldn't call myself a boy necessarily
but if you'd like you're right what go
along with me you'd say you're a good
boy right sure I'm a good boy well go
and get those cookies you like those
Italian crackers that you price Oh
biscotti biscotti Ole Miss Galini won't
you go get some of those okay okay
humor me yeah no one cares it's just an
Italian cookie it's your favorite treat
wouldn't you say Jordan
there should be a slot in the Ferb oh
there's a slot for dog treats
yes right can you put some of your
favorite cookies in there the the
Italian biscotti in the in this [ __ ] hey
you've now put them in that that hole
right yes premium expensive okay I am
now going to control from my there's a
little button here George just to
reiterate you think you think you've
been a good boy yeah good boy okay here
you go
okay have another one
[Music]
okay yes now three you think you can
catch it in your mouth routine that
thank you jeff goldblum circa the first
dinosaur movie on the island here we go
now you see the power is not great
enough to achieve no I know you can put
it in your mouth okay I've seen you in a
bus station listen try Jordan try open
up nice and wide this is important
Jordan right right I want you to be
entertaining so whatever you need to do
to feel fulfilled
I don't think it's possible to catch due
to the aforementioned chaos theory it's
possible to catch this in my mouth
Jordan please listen to me um this is
you know if this is any consolation I
haven't been this happy and weep really
try and catch one really just try I mean
you know where the hole is right I guess
the holes so what if you got your mouth
really close to the hole okay just
really get your mouth right up to the
hole I'm right up to the hole now the
impact the trajectory the speed of the
projection is too fast what do you mean
how could it be too fast if your mouth
is pretty much surrounding the hole
won't the cookie go right in you want my
hole yes I do
yes mouth on the hole please yeah that
was fantastic
are you okay with me keeping the phurba
there Jordan during the quarantine a
tional ii summoned me into this room
unannounced asked me to put my mouth up
to this hole and catch a projectile of
Italian cookies
yes sure I'm okay with that okay take
care Jordan I miss you too bye-bye